so what was like the early years of
anime youtube like then
like and like so you that was over like
what well how long have you been new
youtube before 12 years did you say
um since 2007. okay so how was the anime
so how was the antitube spear from 2007
to 2012
it was like slow right it was very slow
so before 2012 which is which is i kind
of like where
i think you came along um it was
the quality was not good obviously um
as as it is but it was it was it was fun
i don't know
i i kind of in in a way i'm going to
sound so boomer saying this but i kind
of miss
old youtube where kind of anything went
always looked
back fondly at the time when it was
smaller yeah more manageable because it
was more intimate
yeah yeah you'll always look back at
that period especially on youtube right
so i'm sure you all
missed the time when you made like one
thousand you could just talk to random
people
no no you're like why you're so cool
yeah you know i remember i made a video
when i hit a thousand subscribers and i
thought i'd made it i thought
i thought mom i'm dropping everything
dude i i swear like i've always said
this to people but
the joy of hitting a thousand
subscribers is
almost comparable to hitting like a
hundred thousand or a million
subscribers yeah yeah yeah because a
thousand
is just like whoa because a thousand is
like monumental
it is because it's a number that is very
easily
like quantifiable yeah but it's also
huge because like
thinking like wow there's a thousand
people who like me yeah
because once it gets to like a million
it's it starts to become
something that you just can't really
comprehend yeah like physically
whereas a thousand is like holy [ __ ] i'm
popular i'm [ __ ] popular
and that back then it was just it was
you know as it grew into it was all
about doing anime reviews and
a lot of people had different styles if
you came in with an editing software you
you were just
you were just you were the goat you were
the [ __ ] this guy get a little
this guy i remember when like yay otaku
and tristan glass reflection
reflection came along and they used sony
vegas to edit that video
and it [ __ ] blew my it blew my mind
they used a paid product yeah just
some of the stuff they could get away
with that i couldn't using like putting
images on windows movie maker
what the [ __ ] it was basically a
glorified powerpoint
yeah yeah but i think my favorite anime
reviewer from back then was this guy
called
grumpy i [ __ ] love him i do not know
this
he's so good yeah yeah he he's an og and
he doesn't make
videos anymore but what he do is that
he'd he'd do anime reviews but
he'd do it in like the middle of some a
desert in arizona somewhere
right you would review an anime while
like hiking through the dish yeah yeah
yeah
so so what so he was like he was he was
basically pre casey neistat
because what he'd do he'd always start
off his
videos with like uh with like uh
uh with him walking towards the camera
in like the middle of the desert so what
he would have to do
is that he would have to set up his
camera
hike like hike away off screen
and then [ __ ] hike back into view of
the camera
it wasn't it wasn't like he was hiking a
short distance he would be literally
like hiking over hills and mountains
sometimes to get to the camera
and yeah he how long was his intro like
just two minutes
because it was just like super sped up
and you just see him walking towards the
camera so
it'd be like it'd be like a squirrel
just like scurrying like towards the
camera
and he's like today we're going to talk
about berserk
this sounds amazing and i love as well
how a lot of his reviews he
he always had like a place to go right
so he would start
with at the front of the trail being
like today we're going to talk about you
know hunter hunter
and then as he's walking he would talk
about the show and then usually
the one i saw i forgot which anime it
was but he was hiking up this mountain
yeah and i don't he must have like
perfectly timed this [ __ ] like he must
have done the hike beforehand because
the moment he got to the top was when he
finished his conclusion on the show
yeah and he was just like i've made it
to the top guys and that's the end of my
review yeah yeah
and like that's [ __ ] like thinking
back because
thinking back it was it was very
different from what everyone was doing
we were just like
ah old man reviewing anime that's pretty
weird but thinking back he was
a lot of his ideas were really cool he
was you know he was kind of ahead of his
time
he was ahead of his time yeah and that's
that's why he stands out to me apart
from the guy who [ __ ] killed himself
i guess
no not killed himself killed someone
else um
but yeah it's it was kind of like the
wild west back then i mean all of you
i mean it wasn't the interesting west
bank yeah what's the so if that's the
first era right where you're like
you know 2007 2012 what came after that
what's like the era
um what years are we talking between
interesting because i didn't start till
2015. so all of it before that
is like yeah i'd say around about i
can't remember exactly when it was
founded but that was that was kind of
like the wild west of youtube where
everyone was kind of doing their own
things it was it was a mess of different
things
and then 2012 was kind of what like
where the annie tube community really
started to form into this one
one conglomerate and i think the big the
big
event that happened was probably potaku
potaku is huge